let's talk about primary elections which
are often known as primaries one way to
think about them is that they're just
preliminary elections used to get down
to a fewer number of candidates a very
simple example would be let's say there
is a congressional seat in your district
and there's three folks who are
interested in that position who
associate themselves with the democrats
and let's say there's also three folks
in your district who are interested in
running for that position who associate
themselves with republicans there are
some situations where you can have just
a big preliminary election where they
all run against each other we'll talk
about that in a second but usually you
have a situation where they try to think
about well let's just pick one to
represent the democrats and let's just
pick one to represent the republicans
and so that's where the primary election
would happen so you would have a
democratic primary where these folks
would run against each other and whoever
gets the most votes would then go on to
represent the democratic party in that
election so let's say that person wins
then they will go on into the general
election
likewise these three folks would run
against each other in the republican
primary
and whoever gets the most votes let's
say it's that person right over there
they would go to the general election to
go against likely the democrat right
over here so this is the person who
would go against the democrat and then
they are going to compete in the general
election
against each other head to head and then
whoever gets that would get the
congressional seat
now there even in this type of primary
you could call this a partisan primary
there is an interesting question who
votes in this democratic party primary
who votes in that and who votes in the
republican party primary and there's
actually two systems for this or two
general buckets and there's some nuances
from region to region but one way is
that well only registered democrats
could vote in the democratic primary
pick who represents their party in the
general and only registered republicans
can vote in the republican primary that
situation where only registered folks
can vote in their respective primaries
that is called a closed primary
it's called closed because it's not open
to just anyone who wants to vote in the
primary only the people who have already
registered that party can vote
now you can imagine the opposite of that
is the open primary so open
primary
where even though these are partisan
primaries you are trying to figure out
who's going to represent the democrats
and who's going to represent the
republicans you can allow people who are
either not affiliated with a party or
even people who are affiliated with the
other party to vote in your primary so
for example in this democratic primary
there could be for some reason folks who
feel passionate about this candidate who
are actually registered republicans but
who they want to vote in this primary or
you could have people are unaffiliated
who would vote in this primary if we are
dealing with an open primary
now one interesting question is is what
could how could the dynamics change if
we're dealing with a open versus a
closed primary
well political scientists like to think
a lot about this and even states like to
think about this in terms of what is
appropriate what is most representative
what gives the people of that state kind
of the fairest voice in their elections
now people who like closed primaries
might say well look we're trying to
figure out who represents the democratic
party it should only be democrats we're
trying to figure out who represents the
republican party it should only be
republicans
now criticism of close primaries might
be well
if you limit who gets to vote in the
primary then these candidates are only
going to cater to the base they're only
going to cater to the interests of
people in their party and in particular
they might cater to people who are at
the extremes of their party for example
let's say we have a situation like this
let's say that this is the population
right over here and people at the right
end these are conservatives
conservatives
conservative
and these folks right over here are
liberal
and if you were to look at the
population as a whole let's say the
distribution in the population let's say
it looks something like this you have a
little of some people here who are quite
liberal
and then you have actually the bulk of
the people who are someplace in between
and then you have another bump of folks
who are actually quite conservative
so you would guess that hey look you
know a view that someplace in between
maybe a moderate view would actually
maybe be most representative of the
people but if you have closed primaries
what might happen
well the democratic primary the people
who would be eligible to vote would be
these people right over here
would it would be these people the
people who have registered as democrats
and in the republican primary well only
the register if it's closed only the
registered republicans would vote maybe
these people right over here and these
people in the middle these would be the
unaffiliated with a party people
and so
if you have different candidates here
let's say that this is candidate
one where they're here on the spectrum
this is candidate two which is here on
the spectrum and candidate three is here
on the spectrum you could imagine that
for this population they're all going to
say things that speak to
this group and in particular they might
actually the person who wins might
actually be very successful of getting
the people at the extreme left right
over here and so that person maybe is
the person who goes off to the general
election
likewise the same thing might be
happening on the republican side
you have the different candidates maybe
their personal views put them right over
here and it's this person who is
furthest to the right who's really able
to appeal to the folks
right over here who ends up winning and
represents the republican party
well then what happens in the general
election
the entire population has to pick
between folks that actually are more
indicative of either extreme that may be
the closed primary system it wouldn't
have been so good for a candidate who is
reasonably moderate on the democratic
side maybe someone's there or a
candidate who is right over here
or maybe there's a candidate whose views
are right in the middle first of all if
they want to represent a party they
would have to
pick one of these parties and then to
have a shot they would have to represent
views that would be to the left or to
the right of where they truly are and
maybe they wouldn't have as good of a
shot as the people who actually are
quite liberal or the folks who are
actually are quite conservative so
that's a criticism of the closed primary
an open priori might make this a little
bit better because you have these
registered democrats here but folks from
here might decide hey i want to go vote
there as well so they might moderate
things or folks from here might say hey
i want to go vote here as well now
critics of an open primary would say
well those aren't the people who really
are registered in that party and you
could also have a phenomenon of rating
where people in maybe on the republican
side could say look you know what
i know who's going to win here the
republican primary doesn't need my vote
i'm going to go and try to pick the
weakest candidate on the other side so
that in the general election my
candidate has the best shot
now a third type of primary is known as
a blanket
primary often a non-partisan blanket
primary in a non-partisan blanket
primary instead of going through this
political this partisan process
all the candidates here would go into
one preliminary election
and in that preliminary election the top
two candidates would then go on to the
general election now what's interesting
about that so two candidates are going
to move on in a blanket primary a
non-partisan blanket primary and what's
interesting there is you can actually
get two candidates from the same party
going proponents of blanket primary say
hey this is the fairest of it all
instead of making things partisan just
let everyone run against everyone else
and the top two will then get to the
general election
now you'll see all three of these in the
united states at congressional elections
or even statewide elections but if we're
thinking about presidential elections
we're thinking mainly about these two
and when we're talking about
presidential election these are part of
primary season where it's thinking about
how many delegates candidates would get
during the national convention where
they actually pick their candidate
i'll leave you there it's an interesting
way to think about the different ways of
voting especially preliminary voting in
a preliminary way to get down to a fewer
number of candidates i'll let you think
about which one you prefer